Dan Slott ruins everything all right so
if I were to clarify what I said last
time because I know it's going to be
confusing all right miles
I think doesn't have a personality that
sticks out to me quite as much as other
spider-man character like you know
alternative oh Jesus
please don't die please no I I was
holding it ah it's like everything I
don't like miles that much all right
take two whatever let's go do this
get back here you punk-ass little bit so
um miles like when you think about
what's interesting about Peter Parker
you think about like just the character
traits that that are interesting about
him and I go like well you know how
would Peter Parker react to the
situation what would Peter say to this
or you know what would Peter do like
this but then when you think about mild
the thing that kind of annoys me is that
he operates purely off of just doing
what Peter would do like that's his
gimmick but his gimmick is sort of that
he's like the second generation and
trying to learn from spider-man
myself
okay well thanks for that but he's
trying to learn from Peter and goes how
was he to handle this situation so
instead of yeah take that I got a hidden
instead of really dude like I want to
see how miles would do this you know
that's what's interesting about Miguel
O'Hara is that it takes place so far
ahead of the original spider-man that he
doesn't really give a [ __ ] how Peter
would have handled a situation so he
does it his own way and that's why like
spider-man 2099 is willing to like split
someone throat and then kicked him off a
bridge if they piss him off because he
doesn't he doesn't care about following
the example of Peter really he cares
about doing things how he would be yes
Peter Joe I can tell you from experience
Pete everyone looks fat in a spider-man
costume Tobey especially even if you're
not fat
hey stop running away
shitty Ironman
now that's elaborate I'm glad that they
decided to model the inside of this
building specifically just so we can
have the seen how our fall damage I
forget I always forget
there's my health pick up please all
right whatever on you get [ __ ] you and
then you are going to fly away
I feel bad for talking over a lot of the
funny things Peter says in this game but
at the same time it's like there's just
so much dialogue in this game that lets
playing it is impossible and less you
you're willing to kind of chat over the
dialogue 1500 token plus key every time
what is wrong with do I really want to
get 100% machine that bad
I'm not going to why are you stopping
what are you doing are you being slow
okay
all right what I'm confused right now
where are you
Liz never happen before go faster
hello anything I'm saying getting
through there I snap the madness right
come on go faster
stop being a snail choking all right
I guess we're doing the rest of mission
like this now he's gonna miss thing come
on faster snap you out of it dude
seriously trying to prove that this
games awesome with this you're just kind
of not helping Wow
he's he's really going for it like
you're trying to piss me off and it's
working all right well looks like we're
gonna gonna try one [ __ ] no uh and I
put in way too much [ __ ] work this is
this is silly
this is asinine this is me wasting
massive amounts of time miles he also
seems like a very reactionary character
like just kind of you just never sits
around and goes yeah here's my take on
things or here's what I think about life
he just kind of like because I read the
first like 20-something issues of
ultimate spider-man after my like show
that much and then it got like canceled
and then relaunched is Miles Morales :
the ultimate spider-man which was it I
hate when they do that with the ultimate
universe is just barely changing the
title and then restart from the zero
Ultimate Comics B ultimate is the worst
title for a comics ever because god damn
is it hard to like find those in its to
work
this time you're not going to like it
all slow and stupid right unless hitting
and makes that happen in which case I
should probably stop taking potshots but
I'm angry dammit I deserve to get a hit
in you know miles has been in how many
canceled looks by now I just I'm not
going to say that sales are like a
defining factor of quality but I think
it's generally like Peter and Miguel
that kind of win people over and it's I
don't think it's because they're white I
don't think there's any kind of race
component I think it's just like who's
got the most interesting stories I will
always stand by the idea that you know
comics shouldn't be about politics I
think it's just whoever telling the best
stories is the one that's going to be
winning and I don't know the Regent kind
of sucks can we be honest here he's
trying so hard to be like the cool new
hip Marvel villain but region is [ __ ]
lame okay
Regent sucks and that's fine you can
like like politics can be part of comics
know that voice crack in fact we
wouldn't have characters like Captain
America without that but at the same
time when it becomes like the sole focus
is just to like prove a point it just
kind of gets annoying in fact I
constantly worry whenever Brian Michael
Bendis write the comics because I always
go how is he going to work like race or
gender politics into this or something
with the stuff he's written recently
anyway because I used to really love his
work but then it just became like you
know
like I guess I'm okay like I'm really
excited that Jessica Jones is a woman
because I don't have to worry about her
getting replaced by some other character
for the sake of like kind of fulfilling
a a diversity quota
that's that's something I think Marvel
has a problem with lately is that
they're not making like cool characters
that are new and unique they're just
kind of like let's rebrand like an old
one with like a new twist and that works
to a certain degree but then it gets
kind of like obnoxious because I feel
like the new generation of characters
it's like because you know there's all
these lineage characters now I feel like
they're always going to live in the
shadows of the previous version like no
one's going to look at Jane Foster and
say yeah that's or they just say lady
sword even though that's not even the
official title they just in their brain
go yes girl for when they see Captain it
when they see you know Captain America
with Sam Wilson they don't see they're
just going to go get the Falcon if they
don't say yeah that's Captain America
they say that's Captain Falcon or
something you know but with a character
you know what I see writing and spawned
before but I'll say Vaughn is a cool
black character because spawn is not a
remake of another character spawn has
always been black and that's not a
defining feature of him it's just yes
Vaughn cool any also happens to be black
and I think like I think I want to see
more like you know diversity and
characters with like original ones like
they have their own powers and stories
like I'm down for like different races
of characters and even gay characters
would be cool just not when they're a
rebrand of someone else gee I wonder
which violates gonna pick up know the
one that's modeled again this leads
nowhere completely bad I just wanted to
talk before
but I'm starting to think you need a
good old-fashioned kennel
so uh you know I've been rambling a lot
about like race and stuff um this part
like token okay can I can I thread the
needle yeah I did I didn't get any fight
a single one of those all right come
back here yet I still feel like he's
flying slower like I feel like I
shouldn't be able to see him it's weird
either he is flying slower or I've just
gotten a lot better at flinging lately
but either way I feel like I should not
be seeing him right now you should be
like a mile ahead of me alright let's go
do our boss fight
you very irritating really oh I like to
think I'm more charming than irritating
what a cool country all right you know I
really liked the design for beetle in
this but it's like in his costume is
kind of stupid in the eighties comics
and even more so and even earlier ones
but this design for him has been was
just so sod they're like yeah that's
like the canonical way he looks now
because they even use this design for
his suit like they use this design for
his costume in like Lego Marvel and
action figures and stuff that aren't
even related to the ultimate game oh
well that sucks
I just couldn't catch myself [ __ ] and
that's also really annoying considering
how like I know the way this fight team
goes come on stop falling there we go
I'm gonna just wait down here while you
do that
oh come on can he just like backhand me
with a grenade like styrax
Oh fun fact I love Mortal Kombat those
games are great I like the really stupid
overcomplicated lore that beau canes
have
we gonna hide down there or should I
come up here whoa do your senior charge
attack things so I can go kick you in
the face you're not going to do it until
I get close are you
again
do the thing so I can dodge it all right
Oh God
no don't area I was like punching as I
was falling so I couldn't quite catch
myself stop flying away you [ __ ]
Oh God
cousin beetles kind of a cool design
like you know he doesn't have like
anything going on character-wise you
know in terms of personality but boy is
his design and concept cool like he just
likes evil Iron Man with grenade
he should being more stuff
you know who else would be a fun villain
for spider-man ps4 slide that could be
so fun like you could have just do so
many cool things with the in-game
physics with slides straight because
slides whole like gimmick is that his
suit like he negates friction or
something so he can just slide all over
the place because his power is nonstick
cooking spray so aside from like the
pads on his knees and his lovers his
entire suit just he's been pervious to
like being grabbed on to so he just
slides all over the place and like
spider-man web just like slide off for
him like water on on rocks you know cool
because I actually don't think it would
I also get slide died at some point like
off-screen and then was replaced by a
random police officer and they never
really did anything story-wise with that
because I guess no one cares although I
think is the worst spider-man rider
that's another question that I had ugly
whiteout how did that if it's like a
vertical okay if it's a horizontal laser
why is it hitting me when I'm standing
below stop fighting whoa wow I'm getting
my half kick now here let's just finish
this off
there we go see you later
where'd he go where did he go no
seriously that just figures hey I know
you get this all the time but any of you
see a big scary robot guy with a
backpack blackberry and empathy that's
just damn it
well uh-huh
thanks beetle you're a cool fight and
I'm sad that I broke you temporarily I
hope I'll get you all that in a comment
for like bringing that like kind of you
know like you can't talk about modern
marvel comics lately without kind of
talking about you know racism and sexism
and gender identity and all that sort of
stuff like you have to bring up the
politic East stuff just because that's
how the books are lately and I don't
think these characters that have come
out lately are made entirely to the to
fill a diversity quota but it sure it
starts to feel like that after a while
and like no one's really buying the
books is what makes me sad like people
wanted there was such a massive push for
diversity comics and that's great like
I'm totally behind that but then the
books themselves like a lot of times it
kind of lazily written these the new
characters are all way too good at
everything and don't have a lot going on
in terms of personality and then there's
also like no one's buying the new comics
with the diverse characters like
remember when a couple I remember a
couple years ago when silks came out and
everyone was like it's the first Asian
female lead the first Asian female
superhero from Marvel and while that's
totally not true
like a lot of people accepted that as
truth at the time and we're really into
it and silk was making crazy sales but
then like a couple years later she just
back to being one more
your characters no one gives a [ __ ]
about and I think if the writing is good
people should go out and go pick up
these characters like if you're one of
the people who is like I absolutely have
to have a gay comic book character and
then Ice Man you know comes out you
should go buy Ice Man comics to show
your support and if the writing isn't
good then you know don't don't buy it
don't buy a comic just just to support a
cause you should buy it because you like
it but if the writing doesn't represent
that well then that that's there so I
guess what I'm saying is I want Marvel
to what they can do whatever they want
with their characters I have no say in
it I'm just a guy who reads this stuff
and is a connoisseur for it at the end
of the day I'm not going to make any of
the big decisions about their stuff but
if the writing is good people will
respond and they'll like the new
decisions and the new decisions lately
aren't yielding really great comic sales
and that's why DC rebirth is kicking
their ass right now sadly so I think
what Marvel needs to do is if they want
to keep doing the diverse characters and
they want to keep like subtly kind of
replacing the older generation fine sure
go for it just make sure it's not
stupidly written and I think one of the
biggest offenders of that has been
distance elf and that's sad because I
really love a lot of his earlier work
this is tricky just like have a stance
on this because I know I'm going to piss
someone off but I I don't like a lot of
recent Marvel comics and it's not
because of the changes that Marvel's
been making it is more so because the
stories don't interest me like even
characters that haven't been changed
that much
like I don't know like more recent
Deadpool stories haven't been as
interesting to me as Deadpool stories
from like three years ago by the same
writer and that's another reason why I
haven't been buying them as much
so it's not entirely about the sort of
politics that have seeped in but those
are a factor in it and I I'm really
hoping that in the next year or so like
because because Marvel's also gotten
like way too crazy with doing big events
that and those are just [ __ ] over
everyone's continuity by constantly
having to do tie-ins with civil war and
the secrets Hydra invasion and
everything so they should definitely try
to work on like you know chilling the
hell out with a crossover event and just
tell good stories like that's what
that's what I want so no I don't
particularly like miles that much I
don't think he's really that interesting
of the character and it's not there's no
racial component in it although I'm sure
a lot of people have also considered
that I think what what Miles Morales
needs is for someone that isn't Brian
Michael Bendis to write him because I
think Bendis has no idea what to do with
the character and that's why he keeps
shoving him into random teens and then
you know having him get rebooted
constantly which like new number ones
every few months or now he's dating
Spyder going all of a sudden like just
chill out evac get someone else to write
it because if you're going to insist
that Miles continues to exist the you
know he needs to have interesting things
to do is that fair and am I being an
[ __ ] like everyone in the comments
give me your sort of like thoughts about
the way Marvel has been lately all right
how about that and if you agree with any
of my points tell me and if you disagree
you know let me know I want an actual
conversation and then for the future
parts of this series I won't talk about
politics because that's [ __ ] boring
to talk about for multiple parts of a
spider-man let's play but
let that be the theme for today's
episode sit down
okay but remember when Activision made
things that work call of duty neither do
I